I love jamming out to a good song, it can
totally change my mood.
But what if headphones could actually get
you high off your tunes?
Hi guys, Lissette here for DNews.
You know those moments where you put on your
headphones and dive into your own world?
Where everything just feels great?
Music is often an external expression of our
emotion, and we use it to guide our own.
But now a Florida startup claims its product
could turn your tunes into mood enhancers.
Called Nervana, these headphones allegedly
trigger the release of additional dopamine
in your brain.
How?
According to the company, the headphones work
by adding a low-power electric pulse that’s
matched to the beat of the music.
They explain that an electrical signal is
sent through the inside of the ear canal and
to the vagus nerve, which causes a release
of brain chemicals that make you feel good.
Supposedly.
Now, there *is* research that shows that stimulating
the vagus nerve does some pretty weird stuff.
The vagus nerve is the longest cranial nerve
in the body.
It’s name means wandering, and oh boy does
it get around.
It has branches not only in the ear but in
the heart and lungs and gut, and it plays
a crucial role in regulating our parasympathetic
nervous system.
When the nerve receives certain signals from
stimuli, the vagus nerve tells the brain to
release certain neurotransmitters, like calming
GABA, stress inducing norepinephrine, and
mood changing serotonin.
So by “hacking” this system, we could
potentially control it.
Which is the idea behind these headphones.
But they aren’t the only gadget on the block
claiming to hack your body…
Another product called “Thync” also claims
to change your mood by tapping into another
nerve.
The smartphone controlled wearable device
includes two strips with electrodes that attach
to your head and send electrical signals to
nerves in your face, like the trigeminal nerve
in your forehead.
A study in the journal Epilepsy Behavior found
that stimulating the trigeminal nerve can
help treat depression and epilepsy, and a
peer-reviewed study conducted by Thync found
that it can “significantly lower levels
of tension and anxiety.”
One writer claims that Thync gives him a bit
of a pick-me-up, similar to a cup of coffee
and helps with relaxation.
Another interesting piece of tech is a light
called Lucia No.3.
Its makers claim it can induce a kind of meditative
state by combining flashing bright lights
and music.
They claim it activates the pineal gland.
Which yes, light does seriously affect the
gland because it’s part of our circadian
rhythm - it’s responsible for the production
of melatonin, the chemical that makes us feel
sleepy.
And there’s some evidence that maybe the
pineal gland makes DMT, a molecule that can
trigger some serious psychedelic experiences.
So it’s plausible that the light works.
Anecdotal evidence from BBC and VICE journalists
reveals mixed results.
Some say they see psychedelic images and colors,
kind of like synthesia, others say it’s
more uncomfortable and makes their eyes twitch.
As for the headphones, well they’re on the
right track.
Vagus nerve stimulation has been around since
the 1990s.
Researchers found that an electrically stimulating
device implanted* in the chest and hooked
up to the vagus nerve can help ease epilepsy,
treatment resistant depression, and even rheumatoid
arthritis.
One journalist who tried the headphones said
she felt she had reached a personal high point,
her happiness was 10 out of 10.
So who knows.
We’ll just have to wait and find out.
Dnews labs anyone?
Some people have orgasmic experiences without
gadgets though… for more on brain orgasms
check out Laci’s old school epsisode here
Which, if any, of these devices would you
want to try?
And, I’m curious, what do you listen to
when you need a pick me up?
Let us know in the comments and remember to
subscribe so you never miss an episode of
DNews.
Thanks for watching.